professor to Shawn's Ansan you're a
member of the Nobel Committee for
physics and you just presented in about
price this year it is about exotic
matter in the quantum the world so my
first question would be what is this
exotic is not a precise scientific term
exotic is something that expresses our
wonders I'll wander in front of
something that is very unusual very hard
to understand and I think also that has
to be seen historically but it's
exciting exciting for us now might not
be so exotic in 20 or 30 years I guess
you know electricity was very exotic
when it first came around it's not so
exotic and longer but today the basis of
matter I guess we come to that that is
at the basis of this year's price is
really exotic yes so where is this
possible world is in a sense all around
us but quantum effects are not always
very obvious to see but when you cool
down materials to very low temperature
then in many cases quantum effects
becomes very much more visible more
apparent another exotic question perhaps
we have this bagel and you had also a
cinema well they they are actually there
to illustrate something and to
illustrate that is not sufficient to
just show the bagel but I anticipated
these questions I brought also the bond
you see when you put the bond and you
have the bagel then you can see that the
difference is that the bagel has a hole
and the bond doesn't and the important
be the hole is that all the things like
taste or che
or deformations can change continuously
but the number of holes which was
something that we call the topological
invariant it can only change like
integers 1 2 3 0 this is 0 holes this
has one hole I challenge you to imagine
what is a hotter hole but would be to
have ha the hole you cannot have how the
hole you need zero one two and these
this fact that you have integers that
are of topological nature that's
intimately connected to the effects and
the description of these faces that is
at the basis of the browser hero in this
novel price of the year what worked what
was the role of the apology well the
rule of topology is there are many roads
or topology actually one role of
topology is that these so-called
topological invariants I took the
example the number of holes actually
directly gets into the mathematical
description of these faces now it is
takes advanced mathematics to write the
formula that counts the number of holes
in a donut or calculates that there is
here a hole in a cinnamon bun that's
advanced mathematics but do I understand
the concept that this is one hole that
is zero hole that anyone can understand
and that is actually the important thing
for for the basic result where the
discovers of this year's storage
it was theoretical his cover is that we
should remember and it also illustrates
in a very nice way the interplay between
physics and mathematics which we're
theoretical physics is in the actual
etiquette at the crossroad because the
quantum Hall effect which was the
starting point for David Paulus
understanding of it as a topological
effect there was an experiment that was
already done and he explained the
experiment using these topological
invariants while in another case the
case of Duncan Hall Dane who predicted
certain properties of the over ha the
topological states actually changed of
magnetic atoms and also something
similar to the quantum Hall effect but
without the magnetic field that was
theoretical discoveries have predicted
effects that was later seen in
experiment in one case actually 25 years
later and it took much more advanced
experimental techniques to do it they
expect it will come
in many cases when you have a
theoretical possibility since there is
so much variety in experiments you can
do in materials in experimental setups
in many many cases you come up with the
case but it's actually realized you
cannot say for sure but experiments
experience shows that that happens very
often that's of course very exciting
possible applications of this exotic
topological matter in the future I could
just tell you what people are dreaming
about but also working very hard in the
labs to do and that is to get new
materials which has you know interesting
rough properties of conducting
electricity but also conducting other
things like what is called spin and the
dream is that this can be used for carry
information it's also has quantum
mechanical properties something that is
called entanglement that makes people
hope that perhaps you can use these
things to code quantum information in an
efficient way so who knows you know
there might be a future quantum computer
where topological effects are important
we don't know but I certainly know
people are speculating about it can you
tell us about the laureates the prizes
awarded half to David Towers and half to
duncan Haldane and Michael customers
- yeah there are two parts in the in the
citation topological phases and
topological phase transitions that is
how you go in between them and David
Towers has given important contributions
to both of them
- topological phase transitions together
with David towers and - topological
phases he did this important work in
their later whole gain did also very
important work so David Thewlis has a
share in both these parts of the
citation that's why he gets 50 per side